So, it's okay to let Shizuka Yoshimoto be my new girlfriend,
but maybe my brain is rotten.I don't know if my brain is rotten.Who wouldn't dump
us just because I fell in love with a girl who's fatter than me?
Are you such a kind person? It
doesn't mean that the box in your brain is in good condition.To put it in an analogy,
instead of separating the oil from the oil that was there before, you properly encountered it, and the
new oil turned the love you discovered into chemical fuel.
No, in any case, I will show through my actions that I care about the sky and the measure,
and about Moshikaka-chan as much as ever, or even
more than ever.I don't think I will ever feel that way again.
If that's the case, I want you to tell me the
truth.In that case, I'll cut my stomach cleanly too, so you're a man.You're a
man among men.Rentaro-kun, that's what you
deserve.People who hurt the people they care about are the biggest scum in this world.They
live like that.  I already know that it's not worth it. This is how
your resolve has
expanded. Is this strange circle of lovers
okay? Rentaro. How
can you maintain such an eccentric relationship with someone so inexperienced in love? Is he going to commit suicide?
[Music]